parmi tous ceux que vous pouviez
arnaquer vous avez choisi de John Kramer
votre cancer continue de se propager je
crains un compte puisse plus rien faire
il y a une personne qui pourrait
peut-être vous aider notre programme se
fait en deux temps il est administré
dans la banlieue de Mexico les résultats
sont stupéfiants elle m'a sauvé la vie
[Musique]
nous allons bien nous occuper de vous
et ensuite qu'est-ce qui va se passer
vous aurez la vie devant vous
Kramer
la tumeur n'a jamais été retiré il me
reste combien de temps quelques mois au
mieux j'ai encore tellement de choses à
accomplir
je ferai jusqu'à au mollet
[Musique]
bonjour à tous C'est l'heure va jouer à
un jeu
vous avez tous prétendu me guérir moi ce
que j'ai prévu pour chacun d'entre vous
et bien réel
la seule chose que je n'ai pas prise
c'est votre anesthésie mais croyez-moi
vous allez vouloir rester conscient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parmi tous ceux que vous pouviez
arnaquer vous avez choisi John Kramer je
vous en prie n'hésitez pas
mettez un morceau suffisamment gros de
votre tissu cérébral dans le récipient
en verre ça vous s'ouvre à la vie
[Musique]
il ne s'agit pas d'un sentiment c'est
une renaissance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vivre mourir à vous de choisir